I
we're here with Grandmaster Alex drew
pinsky Alex you've won this championship
what's it going to take to become a
repeat winner oh just a poll to be
precise I type the tails in i believe
2005 championship and then I lost my
ploy of much the key card um I would
really like to leave this championship
once but the distal I mean believe or
not i don't have any particular go i'm
just happy to be so you're not counting
that tie for first as an official
championship I kind of time so they're
kind of that's a very modest viewpoint
so in this kind of tournament away would
still be correct to say your goal is to
win not just have a good result too
because my goal is to play 11 good games
has the day of the chess book come and
gone into just all computer these days
for the top tier players computer
preparation is number one how do you use
computer specifically what do you do on
it to get ready mmm normally we are no
wise and critical positions with the
help of chess sanctions what other
things you like to do when you're here
in st. Louis I don't enjoy the park it's
a fantastic product I'm having a good
time the area where chess co-op this is
a fantastic area also the walk and
the city itself seems like getting but
I'd better every year so I already enjoy
to be here now forest park has an art
museum the zoo racquetball tennis
walking what kinds of things you like to
do in the park there oh I'm also just
booked it's very nice environment the
nature is unbelievable the park is very
well help I'm Klimek break time well
good luck here in your two weeks here
and we wish you well on the US Champion
thank you Mike thank you for filling